hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mode
vorstellung und zwar von der
qualifikation
ja wir anscheinend schon an meinem etwas
rum backenden mund turiner kennen könnt
was ja auch der jaden heißt der jd nicht
mir gar nicht sicher aus watchdog immer
um sich trägt was quasi darstellt dass
er so eine art detektive beziehungsweise
jemand der einfach alles hacken kann er
kann zum beispiel in dem spiel also
nicht in dieser modifikation jetzt aber
in dem spiel kann er licht hecken er
kann ampeln hecken er kann stadien
hacken
er kann türen hätten alles mögliche kann
sich leute angucken und ihren profil und
daran herausfinden wie gefährlich diese
personen für die gesellschaften etc und
das gleiche wurde auch hier in der
minecraft watchdog modifikationen
zugefügt der download ist in der
beschreibung falls sich selber
herausfinden wollen was sie hier mit
alles machen könnt ihr seht schon was
ich anhabe ich habe hier diesen mantel
an den der jaden aus heißt entscheiden
ich bin ich sicher reise jd ich schreibe
es in die kommentare oder ob ihr auch
mal selber hot stocks gespielt hat kann
er auch sein dass es viele gar nicht
kennen jedenfalls habe ich hier diesen
mantel an und diese beruht also wir
haben ganz normal wie das mittlerweile
bei relativ vielen modifikation der fall
ist zwei seiten wir können auf die
zweite seite steht ihr gak wofür sie
steht weiß nicht geg ich bin mir nicht
sicher ich glaube es halten seite
geheißen bei gigs darf ist es und so ein
bisschen egal jedenfalls haben wir
erstmal einen hut und den code also
einen hut und den mantel habe ich mir
schon eingeholt habe ich alles einfach
nur damit man so ein bisschen cooler
aussieht so ein bisschen detektiv mäßig
und jetzt kommen zu den eigentlichen
sachen hinzugefügt werden und zwar das
monitoring jeweils den aktuell der fact
that star und deshalb weiß und zwar habe
ich die hier schon im inventar und
erstmal ganz grob zu ganz einfachen
elementen die hinzugefügt werden
ich nehme jetzt mal ein bisschen
redstone und so den tnt beispielsweise
und dann nehme ich mir auch mal eine tür
volks habe und
entfernten aus diesem wirklich
wunderschönen villiger dorf was ich hier
gefunden hab ich habe euch mal den zieht
in die kommentare in den links ist immer
immer wenn ich irgendwas linken eine
welt vorstellen schreibe ich euch den
citroen war jede welt schön finde
wir stellen jetzt hier mal einfach es
ruckelt halt so ein bisschen diese
modifikation oder siegt hat er meinen pc
ich wollte mir übrigens bald einen neuen
pc holen also das kann nicht sein was
eben mein pc markt geht aber ich habe
hier so einen tnt und es findet sich
natürlich nicht an
allerdings hätten die weiß nämlich
einfach rechtsklick und damit das
redstone aktiviert quasi nur dadurch
dass ich da richtig drauf gemacht hat
und dann explodiert das dnt und genau
das gleiche gilt auch wenn ich hier zum
beispiel natur hinstelle und hier
irgendwie das entpacken und jedes
hecking weiß der g die tür offen
denn mal so dann ist es jetzt wieder
umgebaut und genau das gleiche dieser
gebaute redstone gibt schon als heckt
redstone den kann man nämlich hier so
einfach hinlegen crafting rezepte etc
könnt ihr einfach auf der website
nachlesen und ich denke das ist keine
mode die man so einfach im zweifel
benutzt man sich einfach mal einfach so
anguckt also heckt redstone ist direkt
aktiviert und man kann auch türen
allgemein mit dem heck in die weit so
wenn man unten darauf klick kann man
diese türen auch mit dem heck in die
weiß einfach öffnen oben geht das ganze
nicht das geht nur unten warum bei sie
nicht und sorry jungs das tut mir echt
total leid ich hoffe nicht dass man
leute kann nichts für mein pc sage ich
dafür geeignet aber ich muss mir mal
minecraft kaputt also das sind erst also
ein paar wesentliche dinge die zugefügt
werden jetzt kommen mit dem hauptsachen
hinzugefügt werden und zwar hecking
jeweils und monitoring device
wir können jetzt einfach mal das
monitoring die weiterhin dazu kommen wir
aber gleich nochmal das sage ich euch
gleich was das ist und jetzt sehen wir
erst mal okay hier sind ein paar
villiger deswegen habe ich extra so ein
winterdorf gesprochen keinen sinn jobs
gefunden so jedenfalls glaube dass
hecking weiß niemand wenn wir ganz
normal recht machen können mit dem
handeln alter er will einfach zwei
e-mails dafür obwohl es ein relativ
gutes mainz sonst muss man wieder ganz
viel erfahrung sondern aber ist ja auch
wenn jedenfalls kam es jeweils nehmen
und stiften also so in knin die richtige
taktik das werk ich glaube der ständige
bedrohung davos dahin muss da hin
gefällt euch sechser pack ich finds von
eis doch jetzt richtige versammlung soll
wir finde jetzt mal raus dass ihr für
leute seid shift rechtsklick wer ist das
denn das ist er aber und das ist ron ron
broker hatte er hat einfach kran dekan
und er ist zwölf jahre alt und seine
occupation also seine beschäftigung ist
priester ich glaube der hat nichts mit
irgendwem überfall zu tun
ok ich glaube die wollen alle hier sehr
schön gehackt werden jedenfalls könne
jetzt einfach wieder über 100 mal
hierhin klicken wir können ich muss ich
muss dich auch noch hecken bruder also
wir müssen einfach aus dem feld heraus
kaufen von denen pds aber richtig
aufträgt unterwegs ich glaube erstellt
eine richtige bedrohung dar so freese
ihr bleibt jetzt erstmal alle hier so
damit ihr hier nicht ab und beugt ist
ganze zwei mal zu erst 22 jahre altes
pharma usa via playstation all das ist
nicht so cool
wir nehmen hier den hier der ist
workshops etc slap also ist es lab ist
es nicht in youtube der aufpasst mit
wetter macht also wissen die bald
matkowitz immer ein stück weg soll dann
ist es ganz wieder entfernt dann nehmen
wir dich jetzt mal dran so er hier
pinky tenbrock für 26 jahre alt und
arbeitet in der blacksmith also eine
schmiede und warte ich noch mal wieder
ganz kurz weg dann gehen wir hier wieder
zu den letzten der sich in dieser zeit
schon so ein bisschen versteckt take
schicken der water sei okay worldwide so
der da vorne haut immer relativ schnell
ab ich hab da ein bisschen angst vor
diesem typen der gibt immer richtig
gehalt so jetzt haben wir auf jeden fall
ist jetzt erstmal was man damit so gut
machen kann das heißt man kann sich so
leute angucken
die sind aber richtig fix unterwegs ich
glaube dass ausgebrochen und um jetzt
noch alles zusammenzufassen
zusammengefasst zu sehen haben jetzt ein
monitoring die weiß wir können einfach
mal rechts klicken
klick für button below to the vultures
car monitor doubleclick an der nature
access der informations es ist
eigentlich information es gibt die das
wort informations informations kein
purer man endlich eine klare gelbe gehen
jetzt auf jeden fall mal auf select
villiger man jetzt sehen wir die ganzen
leute können einfach mal doppelklicken
ok fred 22 dass die bedrohung quasi 22
bedrohung ist nicht so viel last neun
positionen
habe ich denn schon gesehen da es steht
noch mal das was wir insgesamt habe
hancock 50 shades of clay state of play
und statt des ordners jetzt können die
mankos zeit 75 schon ein bisschen höher
dann gucken wir mal an 76 90
london/washington ok leistner und
position 184 195 ok 184 gehen wir mal
hin und 195 okay das ist hier ja bla bla
hieß terna washington köln
london washington bis new district
blablabla ist es okay ich habe jetzt mal
beschäftigen
die wollen mich richtig verwirren diese
schwelle gianetti hassen mich glaube ich
hallo man hey leute ich kann jedoch nie
finden guck mal wie aktiv die in dieser
kleinen hütte sind wir gar nicht wie
viele da drin sind alter die laufende
einfach mal rein und kommen danach
wieder raus wolltest du fred level 9
level 90 sollte am bass kumpel kumpel
vorgesehen wo bis dahin wo es unter
travel 90 infos unter 490 hin
wir müssen auf jeden fall umbringen oder
abführen oder so naja egal ich denke ihr
wisst was ich meine man kann damit ganz
coole sache machen wie beispielsweise
findet in villa der des böses gemacht
hat ich kenne auch ein paar englische
youtuber die dazu schon vor monaten in
review gemacht haben wo die das relativ
cool aufgebaut haben wie beispielsweise
ja da steht eine kiste mit monitor
ingewahrsamnahmen so unten noch so eine
messe lager gebaut sowie in breaking bad
und dann hieß diese person hat wirklich
die der thread 90 hatte hieß dann auch
wirklich irgendwie so wie in der serie
the water white oder
berg und da kann man ein paar ganz coole
sachen mitmachen
ich denke ich konnte euch die mod ganz
gut näher bringen das war's mit dem für
heute ich hoffe euch gefällt es euch
gefallen hat will ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen
zeit mal lieb zu den anderen in den
kommentaren weil ich sie ist ein letzter
zeit immer sachen wie beispielsweise jo
du [ __ ] was soll das du bist gar
nicht erster und so ja das liegt zwar
auf diese ganzen kommentare aber es ist
halt einfach mittlerweile gang und gäbe
und ich möchte ich dass das ganze so ein
bisschen ausarteten dass man sich nur
noch beleidigt das ok-power deswegen die
kommentare auch schon ausgestellt
und ich denke jetzt einfach so ja ich
bin auch kurz davor das zu machen weil
die meisten sachen wirklich nur
beleidigungen werbung in spam sind und
finde ich nicht so cool
deswegen lassen was nettes in den
kommentaren da und auch den anderen
leuten nicht gegenüber download link
findet ihr in der beschreibung und dann
würde ich sagen was das mit der hot
stocks modifikation wir sehen uns in
einem nächsten video wieder
verabschiedungen immer dünner alter